brutale attacke auf oliver pocher der
comedian wird am abend des comeback
kampfes von felix sturm heftig ins
gesicht geschlagen
der angriff erfolgt völlig unvermittelt
ein mann der sich fett comedy nennt und
oma heißt schlendert harmlos am boxring
entlang verabredet mit einer begleitung
zu filmen was passiert der mann geht auf
pocher zu und schlägt ihm ins gesicht
christoph daum der neben pocher sitzt
weitere gäste in der ersten reihe und
vor allem pocher selbst reagieren völlig
geschockt erschrocken sucht pocher den
schutz der security die etwas
überfordert mit der situation wirkt in
den sozialen medien liefert der schläger
omas später eine erklärung für den
schlag pocher habe eine frau verteidigt
die im letzten jahr diversen männern
vorgeworfen hatte sie vergewaltigt zu
haben offenbar freunde des schlägers
roma selbst durch die vorwürfe betroffen
ist unklar jetzt die hinterhältige
brutale attacke auf oliver pocher pietro
lombardi äußert sich als einer der
ersten entsetzt über den vorfall
schreibt auf instagram dass gewalt nie
eine lösung sein darf egal wie man zu
olli pocher und seinem humor stehe